dans cet hôpital proche de new delhi les
unités qu'ovide ne désemplissent pas
malgré l'aide de la communauté
internationale qui a permis à l'inde de
recevoir des équipements pour lutter
contre le coc vide 19
la situation n'en reste pas moins
catastrophique le virus progresse à
vitesse grand v et la prise en charge
des patients déjà contaminés n'est pas
toujours assurée de manière optimale
loin de là on attend des heures sous le
soleil certains s'évanouissent à cause
de la chaleur et d'autres reçoivent des
appels disant qu'ils n'ont plus besoin
de bouteilles d'oxygène parce que le
patient est mort je ne vois aucune
démocratie dans ce pays
vous pouvez demander aux autres ici on
peut peut-être appeler ça une autocratie
le gouvernement de l'état dit que ceux
qui se plaignent de pénurie feront face
à des poursuites pénales
qu'est ce que ça veut dire arrêter
d'appeler cela une démocratie nous en
avons assez
un véritable cri du coeur et une
confiance envers le gouvernement de
narindra maudit qui s'ébranle de jour en
jour si le gouvernement dit qu'il n'ya
pas de pénurie c'est un mensonge parce
que ceux qui ont besoin d'oxygène ne
peuvent pas l'obtenir
alors que le gouvernement dit que nous
avons pris toutes les dispositions
nécessaires et que nous avons toutes les
installations
sur le plan pratique je ne pense pas que
le gouvernement est en train de dire la
vérité
peut-être que 10 % des gens ont reçu de
l'aide mais pas 90% des gens le
gouvernement qui à l'heure actuelle n'a
pas décrété de confinement nationale une
mesure en revanche décidées localement
cela concerne notamment la capitale new
delhi ou encore les états du billard et
du kerala